[Music]
to [ __ ] sit there this is my take on
the Houston thing why I don't have a
problem with what they did okay I still
congratulate the World Series champion
2017 Houston Astros and I'm gonna
congratulate them for finally bringing a
gun to a gunfight
all right who's kidding hood now this is
the thing all these [ __ ] Yankee fans
I'm [ __ ] here and beli Aiken they're
all acting like what Houston did just
fell out of the [ __ ] sky everybody
was playing by the rules and then all of
a sudden Houston sticks a [ __ ] camera
in the [ __ ] wall or whatever the
[ __ ] going on right that's not what
happened everybody first of all they're
not the first people to do it the shot
heard round the world way back in 1951
the Giants might have patted the Giants
win the pennant the Giants by the pen
they had a [ __ ] guy out there with
the telescope relaying signs in they've
had TVs in the [ __ ] dugout the
[ __ ] camera is behind the pitcher I
literally want how many times you watch
games and they're focusing in on okay
when he does that that's a fastball like
some X pitcher telling him what the
[ __ ] signs are okay and lastly
baseball has been [ __ ] up since 1994
okay they kind of rested on the laurels
they without that that is that any say
it's rest on your laurels or laurels in
hatty they [ __ ] wear America's pastime
okay before they came along believe it
or not it was horse racing and boxing
and then out of nowhere right baseball
comes along right and starts chugging
along and all of a sudden they are the
game Babe Ruth children as you Hank
Greenberg Stan Musial Willie Stargell
Willie Mays Willie McGee Willie Willie
all these [ __ ] people come along
right Duke Schneider [ __ ] yeah and
whitey Ford Mickey Mantle
roy campanella Pee Wee Reese Phil
Rizzuto
Ted Williams Ali's Pete Jackie Robinson
Dusty Baker Rowley fingers Ferguson
Jenkins sorry all of these people come
along and everybody's watching right
everybody's [ __ ] watching and watching
they had the number one sport no man
here in and [ __ ] year out the biggest
advertising Aqua Velva [ __ ] Old Spice
all of this [ __ ] goes to the baseball
players and then somehow in the [ __ ]
1970s
all right after the greatest game ever
in 1958 I believe when the Colts played
the Giants did [ __ ] Yankee Stadium
that was to be that was a turning point
but baseball didn't realize it on came
football in the AFL the NFL then they
[ __ ] March after Joe Willie well we
don't guarantee you right I won't keep
you
right they win it and then the [ __ ]
Chiefs come in I believe that they were
the first like you know when it was the
NFL AFL and merged they win the [ __ ]
thing and then what happened was the
super Steelers the Dallas Cowboys the
Dallas Cowboys cheerleaders come with
their [ __ ] titties wrapped in scarves
baseball didn't know what the [ __ ] hit
him right and then they had all those
awful baseball stadiums web then you so
he seemed on this week in baseball wad
up a bad at the pop-up right there these
cookie cutter [ __ ] stadiums it just
looks like you know what the [ __ ] it was
anymore and you had the Raiders with Ken
Stabler he had the Pittsburgh Steelers
with [ __ ] Terry Bradshaw you had
[ __ ] yet Roger Staubach you had
[ __ ] Fran Tarkenton the purple people
eaters the dilib state defense to Steel
Curtain
they came on with a vengeance right then
the NBA was where the NFL was the
[ __ ] decade before they're dealing
with the [ __ ] ABA everybody stealing
their stars cocaine
so don't worry I got a point here
cocaine comes out decimates the [ __ ]
League NFL passes the [ __ ] MLB right
and NBA looks like it's going out then
along come Bird and Magic right save the
[ __ ] NBA five six years into their
career [ __ ] Jordan's coming along
you got the bad boys and then the
[ __ ] Bulls what the [ __ ] going on
at baseball the [ __ ] is going at
different teams winning it every year
yeah just not that scale Yankees suck in
the 80s at all [ __ ] levels out and
everybody grows up on the Showtime
Lakers and [ __ ] Jordan Duncan on
people and Dan Marino lighten up the
[ __ ] 85 Bears on Monday Night
Football
[Music]
right it all got [ __ ] exciting and
what happened baseball was a game in the
past most are odds every Happ Babe Ruth
big fat white guy used to [ __ ] hookers
of you know hot dogs and go out there
you throw a no-hitter at nineteen [ __ ]
home runs in one game most home runs
ever Hank Greenberg 190 most games in a
row will Gehrig and then he died he was
happy it happened considered himself
lucky was all about [ __ ] yesteryear it
was a bunch of thousand year old white
guys with the [ __ ] records right and
they came to a screeching [ __ ] halt in
1994 and they had a [ __ ] strike right
and then they sat back and they looked
at the game and they said what the [ __ ]
happened huh
why isn't anybody watching why doesn't
anybody want to [ __ ] play why are we
getting a [ __ ] ass kicked by the
goddamn NBA in the NFL and they were
like you know or a games too [ __ ]
slow Zeppelin what do they do they
juiced up the [ __ ] ball the guy thing
they [ __ ] held all these goddamn towns
hostage they got new stadiums juiced up
the ball changed the dimensions so
there'd be more [ __ ] offense the
players started doing roids
they all look
the [ __ ] way right Cal Ripken jr.
breaks the [ __ ] Lou Gehrig record
thank you right McGwire and Sosa go on
this roid run and all the owners all
look the other way as we all sat there's
these [ __ ] gorillas came up knocking
this [ __ ] racquetball with the
[ __ ] leather bound he fell over the
[ __ ] fence right and then what
happens oh [ __ ] George Steinbrenner
comes back from his [ __ ] suspension
right and with his [ __ ] money and
influence somehow convinces the [ __ ]
goddamn eye look at the interception the
end of the game convinced his [ __ ]
baseball that it's okay for a team to
spend 200 million [ __ ] dollars and
treat the bottom third of the league
like their own [ __ ] you know farm
teams and that's what the Yankees did
for 11 [ __ ] years alright and about
three years into that [ __ ] the Red
Sox did the same [ __ ] thing
and we both went out there with 180
hundred ninety two hundred two hundred
ten million dollar [ __ ] teams
littered with stars from San Diego
Kansas City Pittsburgh all of these
[ __ ] Milwaukee Cleveland took all
their [ __ ] stars we went into their
bodegas and we raided their shelves
that's what we did and we went out there
with their [ __ ] stars roided-up and
we turned baseball into like a five team
[ __ ] League and [ __ ] the Yankees
had a 200 million dollar team with free
agents from around the league that were
roided-up for 11 straight seasons and
they won three titles okay
the Red Sox did the same [ __ ] thing
and one for so I say this if Houston if
they have to give back their 2017 a
Houston they can't spend 200 million
dollars right this is my
but I mean Yankee friends like but bill
what they did was legal just because
Italy it's legal doesn't mean it's fair
I mean corporations can [ __ ] donate
as much money as they want to every
political candidate out there it's legal
is it good is it good for democracy is
it good for you when I lunch-pail Louise
no it is not so baseball was [ __ ] up
they allowed [ __ ] six teams to do
whatever the [ __ ] they wanted with
everybody else's team go in there
[ __ ] burn down their [ __ ]
farmhouses and pour salt the field and
take their best farmhands inject him in
the ass cheek with [ __ ] roids right
but the juiced up [ __ ] ball and when
they went out there and it was like you
know I mean yeah and [ __ ] all these
sports leagues sat around and just
watched it happen it didn't all these
sports I'm sorry the network's didn't
say a [ __ ] thing I mean the [ __ ]
Yankees whenever they would win a
championship
ESPN who's supposed to be neutral will
be like and all is right in baseball
like wait a minute so the other 29 teams
are just the supporting cast the [ __ ]
are we doing right and then meanwhile
the NBA's going off the [ __ ] rails
right and then then they just keep
trying to recreate bird versus magic
those teams that happened accidentally
into the Isaiah bad-boy Pistons and the
[ __ ] Michael Jordan and the Bulls now
they tried to do that on purpose and
they let guys like Kevin Durant join the
other [ __ ] team that they almost beat
in seven games now you just joined them
I know that's a completely different
story so here's my thing I don't have a
[ __ ] problem that a tier 2 City that
couldn't go out and spend two hundred
million [ __ ] could not keep up with the
you know the bigger market teams went
out and did what the [ __ ] they did I
don't give a [ __ ]
alright I don't I don't have any [ __ ]
problem with it I think it's it's it's
wrong it is cheating but I really don't
think what's been going on in baseball
for the last 15 years
has actually been on the level and I
think that they've tried to fix it my is
my thing I really believe that like all
sports at this point especially just
because of the competition that's out
there as far as you know you kids today
you can play video games you can stream
you can literally whether they call it
cord cutting you don't about that
[ __ ] cable anymore and just have your
apps and you can just disappear out of
the sports world and that scares the
[ __ ] out of them okay because these guys
you know they got wives to get
mistresses they got yachts they got
teams and they got stadiums they got all
of this [ __ ] they they got a big [ __ ]
nut so they need you guys to pay
attention so I really believe that what
they do is they manipulate they do what
they can to make sure that the higher
rated teams the higher rated cities have
the best possible chance to end up in
the Big Dance the best possible chance
to have the bird versus magic game every
[ __ ] year i 100% believe that and I
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says you
cannot convince me otherwise
all right all the [ __ ] rule changes
that they've made to try to make you
know every game like NFL games are never
over like that [ __ ] game 27 to
nothing when I was a kid that game was
[ __ ] over
you know the Packers we're gonna at
least get within two scores make it just
close enough so you'd hang in there and
watch all the [ __ ] commercials yeah
every [ __ ] Super 15 years every Super
Bowl is a [ __ ] blowout now every
single one seems to come down to the
very end like I don't know that's just
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense to me I
just think that it's it's it's you know
and I'm not saying that that those
players are involved I just think that
they do it through changing the rules
okay where you know you can't like that
stupid [ __ ] Patrick Mahone's run for
a touchdown he wouldn't have done that
[ __ ] 15 years ago they would have hit
tackled him like a [ __ ]
back go back a look at the tackling on
that plate like they are so conscious
that it's a [ __ ] quarterback that
those last two guys let him go through
him like like you like Keith like he's
[ __ ] there but ER they should have
lit him up I don't know so anyway that's
that's my whole take on that thing and I
without a doubt I think that you know
they always like this host stupid thing
down in nothing I love too is this whole
[ __ ] thing down in Houston is that
it's alex core and he was the guy you
know anytime people get caught they
always pick like there's always the
ollie north guy like remember that you
know arms for hostages that whole huge
[ __ ] goddamn there's like three
countries involved alright like I
believe it was us and then given [ __ ]
weapons to somebody in the Middle East
so he get hostages out of the lot of
Central America some crazy guy sitting
at his desk I don't believe for one
second that the ownership of any team
didn't know that you someone was cutting
a hole and sticking a [ __ ] camera
although I don't know the devices are
[ __ ] crazy now when the Red Sox got
busted usin [ __ ] and I watches a couple
years ago there was an investigation but
I would stop short of actually think
they didn't I don't think they wore a
wire I don't think they think that's
[ __ ] nuts I think that they you know
did what they did and I don't think like
you could only have players involved so
much because think about it I don't
think every player knows that you the
only way you you just tell the players
you know you're not gonna be trading
right may how do you do that that's my
thing okay once you get it to that level
like the way players leave one team to
another how do you keep that under wraps
if everybody in the Astros knew that was
going down the amount of [ __ ] people
who at the trade deadline just left in
if they just had one guy [ __ ] leave
or one guy gets cut and then he gets mad
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] at SMU that
[ __ ] that football program he gets mad
and then blows a whistle then you [ __ ]
so I don't know all I'm saying is that
baseball has been [ __ ] up for a long
time and every time I go to Pittsburgh
it breaks my heart to see the Pirates
where they're at and it's such a great
sports town and then people are like you
know my grandfather took my dad to the
games and then my dad took me to the
games and now I want to take my son to
the game but my son doesn't want to go
because the Pirates suck every [ __ ]
year
and the owners just take the [ __ ]
payoff you know which is also on them
but I just you know I know it's not the
way to run a [ __ ] league so I feel
like in conclusion if you're gonna let
top teams spend as much [ __ ] money as
they want and then pay off the lower
teams and take all their [ __ ] stars
it's inevitable that somebody else is
gonna try to do something else to try to
level the playing field alright so there
you go there you go and I also hate to
tell you people have been stealing signs
forever
forever it doesn't automatically make
you win that's another thing that's
another like I don't know I mean if you
can't hit the curveball you can't hit
the [ __ ] curveball that's just it and
there's another thing too everybody knew
what Mariano Rivera was everybody knew
he was coming with the cut fastball you
didn't need to steal signs they still
couldn't [ __ ] hit it so I'm not
saying it's not cheating but like the
level of weight that they're putting
this on why all of these sports channels
while they just look the other way at
what teams like the Red Sox and Yankees
and even the [ __ ] Dodgers all the
money that they spent in the [ __ ]
people that they've signed and all of
that [ __ ] these super [ __ ] teams that
have put
together they're acting like it's
competition is it's [ __ ]
I feel like you know I feel like that
was just desserts that that [ __ ]
happened I still think it's [ __ ] I
mean it's definitely [ __ ] cheating
but I mean come on help me man am I
really gonna sit here as a Red Sox fan
and act like the fact that you know the
Red Sox Yankees and Phillies the way we
decimated the Cleveland Indians and we
all won titles you know with [ __ ] was
a Cliff Lee Jim Tom a Manny Ramirez CC
Sabathia CC Sabathia was complainant on
his podcast
I love CC but he also [ __ ] left
Cleveland and piled on with the Yankees
join those free agents and you know
there was a couple of high-profile guys
on that team that we're on steroids you
know uh you know if you're gonna [ __ ]
about one you got a [ __ ] about
everything at that point right I'm
probably not making sense to you but
that's that's just how I feel that's you
know what this is just a guy who hasn't
played organized sports in [ __ ]
30-something [ __ ] years all right